my channel is sponsored by malwarebytes
which means we will have an ad from them
in the middle of this video
hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are going to
be reacting
to the latest battlefield reveal trailer
uh first up the lighting in this video
is a bit strange because it is still
pretty early in the morning here in
australia the reason that i didn't do
a reaction to this one live where i
otherwise might is because
on australian time it was at like 1 or 2
a.m
so i'm going to catch up on this right
now and i'm very pleased to say that i
have not seen any spoilers whatsoever
before i even look at youtube i wanted
to record this to say
i've been a battlefield fan for a very
long time 1942 and vietnam were two of
the first games that i ever played
online
and i have such fun memories of them i
always
get excited about these battlefield
reveal events um and while
my hope my my everlasting hope
is always battlefield bad company
three i know that's probably not what
we're gonna get today
realistically but i don't know yet i
haven't even seen the title of the thing
so let's go find out shall we
okay here it is um i am on the
battlefield
youtube which means i know that this is
called battlefield
2042 official reveal trailer which is
pretty exciting it's about five minutes
long which is actually shorter than i
expected so we'll watch through it
and then maybe like kind of scrub
through anything that peaked
my interest but i imagine it's probably
gonna be some
some fancy cg stuff to begin with at
least
it says game engine footage i was always
gonna be like live action
particles
cool
[Music]
and robot dogs everybody's getting me
with the dog content lately
that looks like it's probably
classic battlefield revolution stuff
it's very pretty
damn lighting
[Music]
oh is that the the uh did you just steal
this tag
like in um battlefield 3
okay
all right i'll take that
i wonder if that's gonna be like some
captcha
[Music]
based
holy [ __ ] that looks good oh my god
damn
i'm so curious if there'll be any
actual building like full building
destruction
my guess is based on the fact that
they've not shown it it's either gonna
be the end of this or it's not present
at all
okay okay buddy
[Music]
i feel like that has to be no to
building destruction
holy [ __ ] that's cool that's amazing
oh my god
incredible i would like to do that in
the video game please
these weather effects the lighting in
this is off the chain
across the board
is that a tornado
oh my god how are they gonna
damn that could be super exciting
yeah wingsuit guy's back didn't work out
it didn't work out for him
oh maybe he'll be okay
[Music]
that's a great trailer my guess is that
that is all
multiplayer
has a single gameplay campaign
this is this is all multiplayer what
they're showing us is a bunch of
different maps here
and there are a few characters that you
see that
clearly stand out which is what i'm
guessing the specialists or the classes
are
this is obviously one particular
specialist who's got a wingsuit
this guy right here the fact that
they've put these colors on him
um means that those are significant so
my guess is that this is gonna be
maybe grapple gun for this particular
specialist and then this armband
standing out so much
makes me think that maybe that is either
i can't think of what that would be
mechanically
but if it's not functional then my guess
is that's cosmetic so
this is obviously a separate class i
think the guy who steals his tag
this guy here is definitely also a
specialist that seems to have
some sort of extra armor here i would
guess like some kind of heavy
it is time to talk about malwarebytes
for anyone who doesn't know malwarebytes
privacy is a next-gen vpn providing a
safer more private internet at speeds
faster than traditional vpns
basically they allow you to keep your
privacy yours
and on the go with true privacy secure
wi-fi and ground-breaking speed
malware whites believes that your online
life should be nobody's but yours that's
why they designed malwarebytes privacy
vpn to be an
always there guard that hides you from
hackers and advertisers
an invisible partner that helps you keep
your location anonymous and a trusted
ally that encrypts all of your traffic
and logs
none of your data all while your
browsing is smooth too you can get
secure internet access on multiple
devices with next-gen protection
designed to keep your privacy yours
while wi-fi is convenient it's not
always safe
sending data over the internet when
using unsecured wi-fi can expose your
most sensitive information like your ip
address passwords and more
using a next-gen vpn like malwarebytes
privacy can help protect your privacy by
masking your geolocation and securing
your personal information
without slowing down your connection as
much as traditional vpns
have you been hacked in the past are you
working or shopping online are your kids
distance learning then you should
consider malwarebytes privacy i'm just
going to watch this
particular snowbit again because it's
cool as hell
amazing and the thing that i find really
fun about watching battlefield trailers
specifically
is the vehicle opportunities so like
even when you're looking at again i'm
assuming these are all multiplayer maps
and that this isn't a single player
debut really at all um is i mean this
like
it's got to be tons of fun to get lost
in and that weather effect if those are
cross map as well i think that that's
really exciting
um what am i looking for the one that
looked like central park looking at
something like this i'm sure this isn't
just
central park in in battlefield you
always just get to look at stuff like
this and be like oh well there's a lake
here so that basically confirms water
vehicles and there's obviously a
helicopter up here there were people on
the rooftops you're like all these
vehicles that i'm gonna get to approach
vantage points from just makes looking
at gameplay trailers more fun to me i've
always found that with battlefield
except for obviously when they have
story trailers
and there was another thing here that i
found
interesting and that could be helpful so
there are clouds here in this particular
segment we're back towards the sort of
the end of the video
um clouds are probably to prevent
uh air vehicles from getting shot out of
the sky
too easily that would be my guess i
don't know if that's just there to make
this look more cinematic or if that is
also an intended weather effect where
you kind of have
cover in the sky a little bit of a
thicker layer of that
um but they also the part where it
crashed
i've got these lines behind them i'm
sure that anyone watching this who knows
the technical terms for these things and
isn't just looking at it
like a game developer would look at it
um
is very frustrated at me but these um
should help with tracking i'm thinking
again assuming that that is something
that is actually going to be in the game
and that this isn't entirely cinematic
um it looks like this is another
specialist too that's another class
there he's got some kind of i don't even
know what that would be maybe like an
emt
that yeah that's totally something
electrical i'm just not entirely sure
what electrical it is
the weather effects look really cool i'm
very
very into what they can do with that um
especially if the game is
next-gen how they can totally mess up
one of these huge battlefield
sandboxes i think maybe we can get some
more information from the website that
wasn't necessarily in the trailer
a world transformed by disorder
battlefield 2042 the next generation of
all-out warfare is coming october 22.
that's good to know i feel like i didn't
get a release date i just didn't watch
far enough
battlefields changing before your eyes
your cutting-edge arsenal at your
disposal the grand return of all out
warfare adapt and overcoming massive
scale 128
player battles hot damn maps an even
greater sense of spectacular large-scale
battles on seven massive maps designed
for the all-out war experience of
battlefield 2042
which battlefield has multiple distinct
combat areas housed
in a single playspace which means more
variety and more meaningful
vehicle gameplay meet the specialists
yeah
did we see ghillie suit guy i might have
missed him choose your role on the
battlefield and former hand-tailored
squads through the new specialist
system based on battlefield's four
classes specialists have one unique
specialty and trait but the rest of the
loadout is fully customizable who
are they we have webster mckay
who has the grappling hook is that going
to be the the blue one
that's what my guess is yeah ex-military
lone wolf survivalist mckay is an ass
kicker with a
conscience nimble allows the player to
move more quickly while aiming down
sights by enhancing
speed related advantages cool um maria
falk a veteran support that's going to
be
gila tour
p is that just peter i don't know how to
say that boris veskowski
and self-fulfilling borrowers seeks to
acquire power and control in a chaotic
world
he's got the sentry system i don't know
what that is on him that's not the dog
is it
oh that's that right there i've got some
glare on my screen because of the sun
okay so he's got a sentry he can put
down
century operator spots the enemy target
when the sentry gun neat
and then a bunch of redacted ones so far
so there are one two there are four of
them
and then one two three four redacted
five six redacted
hmm let's go to the world real quick
as the world stands on the brink of war
a new kind of stateless soldier emerges
from the greatest crisis
in human history how did we get here
decades of chaos
the rise of the notepads left behind the
displaced band together into ragtag
fleets in search of safe harbor
they are families farmers doctors
engineers and soldiers the ones
privileged and the impoverished with
backgrounds that are worlds apart forced
together determined to survive
however with no way to repatriate 1.2
billion people know that's become a
permanent fixture in all economic
military and social policy making
interesting so there are basically a
bunch of people who don't have
countries that they actually have an
allegiance to the blackout of 2040 a
sudden space debris storm creates a
kessler effect causing 70 of all
orbiting satellites to malfunction and
crash to earth damn
both russia and the us claim the other
is responsible for the blackout while
some suspect no pets were behind it and
accuse them of trying to sew anarch it's
an interesting
interesting lawsuit we've got here the
brink of war there is a food and fuel
shortage that ignites a shadow war
between the u.s and russia to maintain
plausible deniability both
sides feel no pat that's what i thought
it would be it was like they got to be
using these guys otherwise we wouldn't
have gotten so much information about
them
notepad task forces as proxies in
escalating conflicts over resources
promising the refugees a piece of what's
left it's a creative way to have just
people from any country or background
just fight for either side which makes
perfect sense in a multiplayer game
in 2042 open war is imminent no pets
have no choice but to choose sides
fighting not for a flag but for their
future
so yeah overall i'm very excited about
this and i think the thing that that
gets me
the most is probably a lot of these like
moments that do look like really
classic battlefield moments the things
that we've seen in battlefield in the
past
like this particular what's it called
i don't remember the name but i've seen
this in like fan highlight videos this
is a thing that is very
reminiscent of old school battlefield um
a lot of this looks like it is
it looks it looks really cool to me
couldn't get any info on their website
about single player so i'm assuming
there is none which is a huge bummer for
me that is always a really big
disappointment i love a single player
campaign and i think battlefield single
player campaigns have been
very good where they have existed i
really liked the approach they took in
battlefield 1.
um so that's a shame and yeah obviously
this is just a really flashy trailer
designed to get me excited and it's
definitely done its job there
thank you for watching this video
everyone remember you can check out the
link in the description to learn more
about malwarebytes but otherwise
i will see you a whole lot over the next
five or so days for so much
more e3 coverage thank you for joining
me and see you guys next time
bye